alright guys bang bang I have the one
and only mr. Olli here thanks for doing
this thanks for having me Anthony I feel
like we are so close in New York City
but yet so far away with you in Brooklyn
and me in Manhattan and just the water
separating us with the quarantine I know
it's crazy what do you think it's better
to be in Brooklyn or Manhattan right now
well according to the numbers they're
both bad yeah okay so what's less bad I
think I think Brooklyn might be winning
man like there's a little bit more space
you know I don't know we'll see all
right guys Olly is one of my best
friends this gonna be a lot of fun you
are the founder of co-venture maybe give
us a quick update what is co-venture
what are you guys doing right now yeah
so a co-venture we do both venture
capital and we do asset based credit in
when I say ask the base credit what we
do is we find sort of novel asset
classes or asset classes that have never
been financed before it an institutional
way and then we lend against those
assets so some of the types of things
that we finance our perishable produce
YouTube libraries you know streaming
revenues ecommerce ad spend all kinds of
sort of off-the-wall stuff and in
venture capital we do early stage
investing primarily in FinTech primarily
enter of newer economies that might be
the YouTube economy or the Spotify
economy or the thumbtack economy etc or
anything where there's sort of some new
invention of an asset class so that's
what we do as a firm we've been doing it
for a handful of years and yeah it's a
summary of us awesome so I want to start
first with the credit markets because I
think a lot of people one don't
understand it and two don't realize the
impact that kovat will have on it
they're usually focus on equities either
public or private equities maybe just
give us a quick overview of like what is
the credit market and what's the
difference between the public credit
market in the private credit market sure
so
oh can you hear me I can't hear you yep
I just just go right from there we'll
clean it so credit marches are pretty
broad right there's broadly debt
inequity you know equity you sell a
percentage of your company and the
person gets a future profit you know
profit interest in perpetuity and credit
you borrow money and you owe some fixed
rate of return in the future and you
know credit markets right now public
credit markets are being hit more than
private markets for now and that'll
change and the reason is people can
respond to speculation so in private
credit you really only have issues when
someone was supposed to make an interest
payment and they don't or they're
supposed to have some sort of asset
coverage there's some sort of covenant
in an agreement that gets breached
example the Covenant might be you know
indirect lending right so you always
hear like private equity companies are
levering up their businesses what it
might mean is a leveraged buyout
occurred a private equity firm put up a
hundred million dollars of equity they
borrow two hundred thousand two hundred
million dollars of equity to complete
the transaction three hundred million
dollars in total and one of the
covenants of the lender is to say we're
expecting this private equity business
to pay our two hundred million dollars
back plus interest with some percentage
of the profits as it'll be some sort of
debt to income ratio that they're
purchasing or levering up or lending
against and then there's covenants
around what kind of EBIT dah levels that
company needs to maintain and if they
don't maintain those EBIT levels then
the lender can say okay now we're gonna
go take over the business and default on
the loan so that's an example of a
covenant or another example might be hey
you had to pay sure you know interest
every quarter every month that's private
markets in public market so people are
you know are speculating so for example
let's imagine there's something like a
mortgage-backed security so there might
be a public security that what it does
is it owns a building and there's some
equity layer right which is like the
actual owners of that
and they may say I own a building the
building's worth a hundred million
dollars and I'm going to put up 20
million dollars of equity and the debt
providers are gonna put up 80 million
dollars of equity now one of the
covenants in that agreement might be
that the eighty million dollars always
needs to be secured by twenty million
dollars of equity subordination well you
know the building is sort of sitting
there and nothing's really changed in
private markets there's gonna be all
this sort of hemming and hawing of
people saying well the building's still
worth the same and once this is all over
it's all going to be okay in public
markets you can see a change in daily
basis and so the public markets do is
they speculate on whether or not the
economy will come back and then if the
price of that equity goes down then the
lender says aha you know I needed to be
secured by twenty percent of equity I'm
no longer secured by that and you need
to either give me the building which
would be pretty shitty or you need to
raise more equity so that I have more
equity cushion and the problem is when
your share price is going down or when
your security price is going down and
you have to raise more equity that's
like the worst possible time to raise it
and so what you're seeing is credit
markets in public markets are reacting
more quickly because the reaction is
either a lack of liquidity because maybe
some of these mortgage-backed securities
can't pay their interest
some of it is speculation in some cases
you're seeing you know prior or
corporate companies say you know I or
borrowers are saying I don't believe
that you know Carnival Cruise is going
to be able to make interest payments and
so you're seeing the bonds trade-off
because let's imagine I had let's
imagine I was carnival and I don't know
what their bonds were trading at right
now but I said hey I'm gonna issue a
hundred dollars of debt and I'm gonna
pay five percent interest on that debt
yesterday or two months ago getting paid
five percent might have been okay but
Carnival is now riskier and so its own
might demand is I want to get paid ten
percent well the way that that would
happen is the bond price will go down so
Anthony if you owned a bond that was
worth a hundred dollars that was paying
five percent I would buy it from you for
something under a hundred dollars
because if I buy
from you for say you know $99 then I'm
getting 5% plus you know that spread of
the discount that I plotted out so
you're starting to see the reaction in
public markets happened a lot more in
private markets
it hasn't there hasn't been as many
defaults yet because it just hasn't been
enough time right so there's like all
this sort of news cycle around what
people aren't making their rent payments
this month I think probably in private
markets people are gonna not gonna be
happy about it but they'll say okay fine
if you miss an interest payment we get
it like a virus is going around
destroying the world like that's not so
good if it happens another month I think
it'll maybe be okay if it happened to
third month that's when you'll start to
see stuff break and the last part is in
private markets the borrower and lender
relationship or maybe a little bit more
sort of close-knit where you know like
if you have if you've securitized your
assets who do you argue with all your
shareholders of the securitization I
don't know but if you have a private
lender and you can call them and say hey
look you know person I know I owe you
money
you can either foreclose on my assets
and then maybe get some percentage of
your money back or you can let me work
this out with you and I'll pay you later
maybe you know I think those are the
conversation that starting to happen
yeah so what's interesting to me is
first of all the relationship you're
talking about here in the public markets
there's and at times thousands of people
who hold this stuff and this is could be
for companies or even the MTA was saying
that you know ridership of the subways
down 90 percent and they're worried they
don't have the revenue to pay their
bonds and things like that so that's a
very different type of relationship and
also kind of lender than if you look
into private markets in the private
markets is it safe to say that in almost
all of these relationships you're
talking about one single borrower being
a company or corporation and then
there's just one lender per relationship
and maybe a company has multiple lenders
but really it's kind of a one-to-one
you're not seeing any sort of like had
to play from an SP B and I'm gonna do
with all the shareholders on the other
side ESP B it depends and so it's a
whole spectrum I mean in the simplest
sense there might be a borrower and
there's a lender and there's only one
lender in the whole deal and the
borrower has a direct relationship and
if the borrower has a really good
relationship with that lender they may
say look we've
working together for 10 to 15 years you
don't want to blow up I don't want to
blow up if you force me to do all the
things that are in the Covenant packages
of this loan I'm gonna default and you
know if you're fun you don't want your
borrowers to default you kind of look
done or it might be a lender who that's
the whole reason they do this they're
hoping you default because if you
default they get to own equity in your
business and so knowing who your lender
is and what your lender sort of goal was
is pretty important you know and then
and then next is also understand the
situation your lender is in so if your
lender is exposed to a ton of [ __ ] stuff
that's like sort of hitting the fan
that's not so good because they might be
acting reaction in a reactionary way or
if stuffs hitting the fan you may be the
least of their problems and they just
don't want one more to fall it's really
hard to kind of figure that out the
other thing is is your lender levered
right so if your lender gave you money
and it gave you a hundred million
dollars but only 20 million was theirs
and they have a bank of um 80 million
you know in many ways leverage is not
good because it magnifies losses another
reason leverage isn't good is you're not
the boss of yourself like you know
usually when we do a deal
we're senior lenders part of the reason
we do that is because you know we don't
want to take more risk than we need to
take and the other part is like let's
imagine I have a portfolio company that
has an issue I almost always know more
about what's going on with that company
then some bank who might be lending to
me where they got like my investment
committee memo and my data room and all
this stuff they don't know the actual
situation on the ground they're not in
the phone with the company every day and
and not having leverage gives you like
sort of the ability to sort of do what
you need to do to make the right
decision rather than doing what you need
to do within the confines of rules that
were set free kovat or Priya
circumstance you could have never exist
expected before there's another
situation where you might have multiple
lenders and those lenders are all acting
differently and I'm trying to figure out
how to navigate what makes sense for one
lender versus another you know one of
the things that's often in terms where
if you have multiple lenders is all
lenders need to be treated pair of
pursue or get most favored nation well
you don't want to be as a lender to a
company where the other lender is
getting treated more
early that might be a situation where
you have one lender who's being a total
jerk your other two lenders or four
lenders or even 5/10 whatever are being
great and you have to figure out how to
navigate all those relationships that
one lender doesn't blow up everything
else but then on the other hand you
might be totally thrilled that you
diversify your capital base which is
something that you often hear and so and
the last part is understanding like if
your private equity owned you know
Blackstone is sort of a big deal if they
go tell their lender hey I believe that
if you give me a little bit of
flexibility here I'm gonna work this out
one they're a really important client to
the lender and the lender doesn't want
to screw that up too they have a lot of
credibility because they've been through
this before if you're like a ring key
being private equity firm that you know
doesn't have that same sort of
relationship with large banks you can't
have those same conversations so it's
really really hard to say this is how a
lender borrower relationship works
because there's so many other factors
involved with what can people do right
now to ruin their relationship right or
reputation so like we hear all the time
hey you could build your reputation over
years and years and years and you can be
the greatest person in the world and the
bull markets when the bear market hits
it's really easy to kind of blow up that
reputation that you've built by just
doing kind of shitty things mm-hmm from
your perspective like what are the
things that are most likely for somebody
to do that then leads to kind of the
hurt on the reputation side is it just
not only - it's what they're supposed to
do or something more complex so you know
so usually when something goes wrong
it's the borrower's fault right they
didn't do something they were supposed
to do in this case like a virus occurred
everyone got sick so everyone had to
stay home and so people stopped spending
money and like it's sort of not your
fault anymore and one reaction might be
to go to all your lenders and say
everything's fine
everything is not fine like I loved my
apartment four times this week like [ __ ]
you if you think everything's fine and
you know one way to ruin your reputation
or confidence from your lender is to be
ignorant or you know one temptation that
a lot of
others and entrepreneurs have is to show
confidence because if you don't show
confidence in the market people assume
things are worse than they are I don't
think this is the time to do that I
think this is the time to say here's our
plan and here's our base case here's how
we think things are gonna affect us in a
good scenario doesn't affect us or
affects us less than we thought
in a base case it affects us and here's
what would happen in a bear case this is
how bad it can get
I've found in the conversations I'm
having with our portfolio the more
worried the founder is less worried I am
the less worried the founder is the more
worried I am because it makes me think
that someone has to worry and it's not
them the second thing is hiding
information you know one temptation is
to say oh my god
you know I'm lending money to because
because often we're working with
companies they're lending money to other
companies and they may have a loan
that's not performing one thing they may
want to do is refinance that loan and
say well you know this is a borrower
that we've worked with for a long time
you know they're struggling and they
already were struggling and this is a
moment that makes it even harder let's
let's let's lend to them again let's put
a little bit more money out because I'll
help them get through this time you know
in rare cases that's the right thing to
do but I would say look like you
normally if you're gonna get yelled at
for making a bad loan this is the time
that you're not gonna get yelled at just
like cut it off and even if it was coded
related people understand if it wasn't
kovin related people are gonna still
think it was Kovan related and give you
the benefit of the doubt so it's a
really good moment to kind of cut things
out from the book or make if you saw
something trending in a bad way make
this the quarter that you read it off
but the way that you can really screw
this up is lying pretending like you're
a more optimistic than you are
committing fraud or doing things that
are gonna put your lender or your
investor in a bad position with their
investors because those are things that
are sort of unforgivable yeah so it
sounds like really a lot of the maybe
the don't dues or just do what you say
you're gonna do don't be an idiot
and tell the truth right like those are
like the big things and if you do that
everyone kind of understands hey look
this is a really bad situation and we're
all in this in various ways
and get ahead of it right I mean it's
pretty think about this it's a lot
easier to have a conversation and say
there's a there's a chance that X Y & Z
thing is about to happen we're working
really hard for it not to happen if you
were us how would you be handling it and
then you bring your investors into the
problem and it becomes their problem too
and then they're brainstorming with you
if it goes wrong later whether it's
right or wrong Gulf thought that they
were part of the solution and now it's
everyone's fault not the investees fault
if you hide it and you want to just tell
people it's gonna be fine and you hope
it is and then later you're like hey
this thing I didn't mention it went
wrong you have you have one of two
options either I didn't tell you about
it even though I knew it might be an
issue or two I didn't think it was an
issue and I'm an idiot and now it's an
issue right so it's just a lose-lose and
so get it your your investors are seeing
so much stuff right now that like there
are a lot more tolerant of information
yeah I know for us with our LPS you know
and and we we are excited and think this
is a really good time to be investing
actually but we said hey this is
everything that could go wrong and in
the event that it goes wrong in the next
few months now you know you end up
having this sort of tricky issue where a
lot of your LP is gonna want to talk
which is fine you want to be over
communicative the hard part about that
is they may have an idea and you may
disagree with that idea and not do it
anyway that's sort of hard but a
majority of them and that's not because
one person is wrong or one person's
right you know it's just if we all knew
what to do we would all do it a majority
of them we're gonna have the
conversation say wow well you're
thinking about this the right way no
matter what happens you've kind of been
communicating so I think you know just a
lot of communication and a lot of
realism and start crappy and then like
get better from there when an investor
calls me I'm telling them all the things
that could go wrong not all the things
that are going right makes sense you
mentioned the covenants and like the
idea that there's conversations that
happen especially the private markets
right now in credit where folks
basically say hey look if you kind of
call
all these covenants are enforced them
I'm going to default and cause problems
for myself and for you et cetera where's
the balance there and what I mean by
that is like why have the covenants if
when things go wrong
people then don't follow them or they're
kind of enforced you know on an ad hoc
basis almost to some degree I mean
there's a spy like all my answers right
now there's a spectrum so in some cases
you so if I write a good loan document a
covenant will be broken in the best in
the worst of times because if a covenant
was never broken it was probably too
loose of a document and when it
inevitably happens in normal times is a
portfolio company you will you know will
be operating and something crappy will
happen or something they never even
expected will happen and you say hey you
breached a covenant but I'm okay either
I'm okay with it because not that
material or I get what happened and I
want to keep being a good lender to its
material and I'm not gonna foreclose on
you but what I do want is to increase
the interest rate right so there might
be a payment penalty there might be hey
you know your assets are underperforming
so I need you to raise more equity to
cure my bar you know my protection you
might say something like hey I'm gonna
like do something to be lenient on you
now but in exchange I want warrants in
your business because the reason I'm
helping you is really to help the equity
the business not really to help the debt
and then the the other is a lender who
did it because the whole time they were
hoping you'd break a covenant so they
could take your business from you you
know one of the into that's that's
always the case and and this is no
different right so the reason the
covenants are in place are one to bring
people to the table the most important
covenants when we're right when we're
investing in a deal is the leading
indicator covenants so we'll often look
at cohort analysis and try to do things
where if something's going wrong now it
means that something really will go
wrong in six months and so what we want
to do is have those covenants so that
when it happens our reaction is not
we're defaulting it's that you are in
default but here's a path towards a cure
that way
we don't get into this sort of emergency
situation later
you know and then and then in other
cases one of the perverse incentives is
actually the better the asset the more
comfortable your foreclosing so you know
in an ideal world what you might say is
if you're sort of the rational investor
you might look at all these investment
opportunities one investment opportunity
is you are gonna buy into the equity of
a good asset you know let's imagine it's
a really nice hotel and you say well it
doesn't have a lot of leverage on it
right it's a hundred million dollar
hotel the debt is only 50 million of the
hundred million so it's not a lot of
leverage
we know that when this is all gonna come
back it's probably gonna stay in
business and the equity is down because
the market said it's down but I want to
go buy-in in a weird way it's actually
that's a riskier asset in some cases
because the lender may be more
comfortable foreclosing on it because
they're pretty sure they're gonna get
all their money back or most of their
money back in another scenario you might
be looking at a deal where it's not a
great hotel and it's really levered you
know maybe ninety percent leverage and
the equities down a lot that lender is
actually more unlikely to foreclose if
they don't have to because if they have
90 of the hundred dollars out and the
true value because a co bid went down
let's call it six percent eight percent
if they foreclose the transfer of the
asset and foreclosure the litigation the
damaged goods are gonna be less valuable
than the ninety bucks back and they may
be afraid of not getting par and so
they're more likely to work with you
because it's no longer the equities
problem it's the equity and the debts
problem so there's all these sort of
interpersonal dynamics that might make
it a little bit less obvious and you
think yeah do you think that there will
be changes in covenants moving forward
after this like what we see pandemic
related covenants or do you feel like
most of the covenants that are in there
today tend to kind of cover along the
issues that hadn't come up during this
no this whole this will get written in
legal docs forever now you know the
question is how do you define pandemic I
don't know what if the president United
States declares it a pandemic seems like
a pretty crappy way to define it and you
know big language is what litigation is
made of so there will be there will be
some
version of it I can imagine there's
gonna be certain industries we're
getting pandemic insurance will be an
obligation you know for the airline
industry for example I can imagine on a
go-forward there's gonna like you know
how banks have FDIC insurance which
basically says well if you're an
fdic-insured Bank you can take deposits
I mean there's gonna be some sort of
like things similar to that to the
airlines where they say hey you know you
have to take a percentage of your profit
and like it's gonna be taxed into this
you know government trust and then in
the event of a pandemic you know cash
will be doled out inevitably it won't be
enough cash but at least people won't
have the same reaction like oh my god
American Airlines that I'll use like
dividends and share buybacks whatever
they did and how crappy of them to now
need government support if they
shareholders did okay I bet you're gonna
see stuff like that I bet you there's
gonna be pandemic insurance that's
broker to the government and then I
think one of the interesting things
that's happening insurance right now
that people are starting to see a lot of
press on is like if you're an auto
insurer life's pretty good most of your
assets were you know cuz because an
insurance company they make money
because you pay them premiums and then
they have a bunch of cash and they
invest that cash and insurance companies
are regulated they're not allowed to do
risky things with their cash because you
know if your house burns down you wanna
make sure the company insurance company
has the cash to pay you out so their
assets are primarily in pretty not risky
stuff at the same time like there's not
a lot of car crashes so auto insurance
is doing great the government I can
imagine telling these insurance
companies that in times of duress or in
times of pandemic we're gonna increase
your tax rate to go into this sort of
pandemic insurance pool and then the
government will subsidize that pool and
you know hospitality companies and
travel companies will also be required
to take out that insurance just like
there's keyman risk yeah super
interesting there's a lot of people who
have said that they are getting more
bullish on going and buying assets now
so whether you know Tomas came on the
podcast and talked about going low for
some good assets however Marcus recently
wrote a memo talking about that they're
they're buying things where they find
value and kind of have switched to a
more aggressive
stance what are the types of assets that
you think people should be looking for
and I know that there's some debate as
to like do you look for the good assets
or the bad assets and kind of how you
think about that yeah I mean look I so I
don't I think a lot of public securities
are being traded on speculation
liquidity mismatches uncertainty around
what interest payments will be have to
pay it or not and not really unlike
going in like driving up to a building I
would anyone go in this building maybe
it's on an ice road and other buildings
around it seem pretty nice there's no
graffiti so you know I think noir in
normal times you look at an asset you
decide how valuable the asset is and you
lend against it and now there's a lot of
market dynamics I don't really got it
respect I don't know enough about market
dynamics to feel like I'm the person to
go do that in my little world of private
credit I don't think that there's a lot
to do yet for one covenants are still
breaking and April and May will be a lot
worse than March and June will probably
be bad and you know it's super cool that
like you know the government's trying to
tell us that everything's okay but it's
not you know no one's going outside in
the world's collapsing and this is this
is really [ __ ] bad you know people
aren't gonna have jobs so I'll tell you
one thing right so like you're not going
outside so you're not spending money and
then we're all gonna get a stimulus
check consumer credit isn't gonna be
that bad in March because also people
got laid off at the end of March
consumer credit even be that bad at the
end of April May it's gonna be [ __ ]
May is gonna be so bad and so a lot of
people are gonna look at this and think
that there were weighing in or that the
markets been corrected and it hasn't you
know and then the other thing is a lot
of entrepreneurs haven't really reacted
to the new reality I think there's still
some sort of optimism and it's good to
have optimism but you know I don't think
like the bid-ask is really kind of come
to reality yet so I'm sure me I'm sure
in public markets or stuff to do because
there's distress and like I'm sure
Apollo reads and Blackstone REITs are
probably good to buy because you know if
Goldman's letting you know Blackstone
read I'm sure black sands not gonna work
with Goldman anymore of Goldman acted
like a jerk you know by the way I
wouldn't want to buy
like the read of like a rinky-dinky
sponsor where like goldman doesn't care
about them so but but in my world of
private credit it's not a lot to do yet
i mean i think what's happening is
lenders are going to their borrowers and
saying hey this seems pretty bad huh
Navarro's like yeah this is pretty bad
what can you you know what can you do
and the let and the borrowers who have
been performing really well in good
times are gonna have a lot of leverage
with their lenders the borrower's are
weren't performing even before this are
gonna have less leverage and they're
working on a plan you know and what in
some cases one of the things that's
interesting is you know right now the
world got riskier so you'd expect
spreads to go up if you have a borrower
who is already struggling the worst
thing you can do to them is make them
pay more interest payments so you have
this super weird dynamic we're sure you
know the risk is going up so you should
be asking for a higher yield but the
company can't pay for it because people
aren't buying a thing you know but if
you're an inventory lender and you've
been lending to an e-commerce company or
a physical retailer against a bunch of
their I don't know
surfboards why not great to collect
those assets right now I don't know if
surfboard sales are gonna do you know
and so there's a lot of stuff that
people are trying to figure out where
it's just not distressed yet and I'd
rather be too late than too early yeah
let's switch to the venture side could
you guys have made a bunch of venture
investments as well how are you seeing
the good CEOs or good companies handle
this situation oh you know I've kind of
talked about like this pandemic playbook
we're basically kind of being decisive
and jumping into action early it's
probably better than waiting what do you
see those companies doing right now that
they walk away and say they're doing the
right thing so I mean so venture kinda
went in this this cycle of waves right
so there's one which is the pandemic
occurred and venture capitalists sort of
view themselves with contrarian thinkers
even though they're not and they were
like oh man markets are down it's a
great time to buy or open for business
and any other venture capitalists are
scared right now what an amateur I've
been through cycles this is gonna be
great and I'm gonna be here with you and
then and that was [ __ ] right because
what happened is all the sudden all
these mostly [ __ ] right
because all the sudden all these DC's
had a handful of companies in their
portfolio who if you have a big enough
portfolio someone was hit really hard
you know in some companies you're gonna
see a dip in sales of 20-30 percent some
companies are gonna have a hard time
sort of doing you know making new sales
and what hit their CRO targets some
companies lost ninety percent of the
revenue and okay so for two to three
weeks that's what you're focused on and
it's not that you don't believe yourself
when you say it's good to buy at the
bottom of the market it's just hard to
spend your time giving capital to a new
company when a company on the board of
is in crisis mode so then what you do
that the next week
you know people kept tweeting or
whatever the hell they do and then
people were saying okay well let's look
at our fun how much dry powder do we
have left what percent of our portfolio
companies have a lot of cash what
percent of them don't have a lot of cash
who are our most important fun drivers
and how do we make sure they're okay and
then let's figure out how much cash is
available for everyone else you know one
of the things that happens in venture
capital is usually VC is focus on one
stage there might be a seed stage firm a
series a firm a series be firm whatever
but when you do a round and you expect
some other firm to come in and do the
next round it's usually on the back of
hitting your plan or hitting close to
your planner growing in a world where
people are gonna struggle to grow like
if you're an enterprise software company
and you're making sales it's probably
not gonna be a lot of sales to be made
right a CFO's can be sitting there being
like I can lay off more of my friends or
I can buy this cool thing and if it's
not a cost saving thing you're not going
to get it so there's not a lot of growth
which means a lot of these VC funds had
to take their fun and carve out a larger
portion than normal for follow on and
inside around to lead inside around
since their portfolio companies that
just means new names will be printed
less right there's just less room for
new deals and so I think most VC firms
have done that now then there's the
stage of going to every single one of
your portfolio companies and going to
like the sort of generalized plan okay
let's go through every single one of
your payables and figure out what you
don't need to pay or what you can reduce
AWS bills probably reduce those sales
force bills probably reduce those G's
Bill's probably reduce those landlord
rent payments probably reduce those so
you literally go into your state your
credit card corporate credit card you go
into your bank account you look at every
outgoing wire every outgoing amount and
say what do I not need to pay and what
do I need to pay later and then you for
shrink your employees which is sort of
the hard part and you decide you know
one if you had underperformers and
companies are notorious for not being
good at laying people off or firing
people who aren't performing often
because they're founded by new
entrepreneurs you don't like having
those conversations you now have the
best excuse ever you know to do that as
sad as that sounds and then you say okay
so if I if I'm not gonna be able to
raise money for 12 to 24 months how much
capital do I need and you often need to
extend your runway and that might mean
even more layoffs and then you say let
me go to my customer list what percent
of my customers are like in travel I
should assume that none of them are
gonna pay me you know what percent of my
customers are streaming services how do
I lean into those customers but I would
be you know if I was an executive on the
phone with all my key customers trying
to figure out how I can proactively work
with them um so those are you know the
basics and then after that every company
is sort of its own snowflake yeah it's
really interesting because I think
there's the two components right you can
grow revenue and you can cut cost but
what we actually will see here is some
companies will suffer pretty drastically
and some companies will actually get
aggressive and steal market share right
and there's simple things like you know
travel and hospitality obviously are
going to suffer for the most part but
then the streaming companies will what
will do well what I wonder is you know
and I thought through a lot like you
don't see every restaurant struggle for
example right so things like Panera is
selling groceries out of their locations
because its way to continue to drive
revenue while they have their locations
open and no one's coming in to actually
dime it or you'll see like a local small
business who says hey you know what we
can't actually have people come in but
we can really ramp up our delivery
business right and kind of go ghost
kitchens etc are you seeing kind of that
ingenuity
you know from entrepreneurs or are
people
the mood of like let me get a lay the
land understand what's happening before
I make any rash decisions I think you
know it's it sounds cool to say wow this
is like my moment to play offense while
everyone else is playing defense I think
that's right
I think the little look if you're an
entrepreneur and you think you're
smarter than a virus you're pretty
[ __ ] cocky so I think having some
humility going into this is important
and you can have a hypothesis that this
is better for your business you know we
have a portfolio company that is in the
sports space and one of their hypotheses
is that because a lot of sports are down
they're actually gonna see an increase
in revenues an increase of the bad but
it's still hypothesis and we're not
taking action on - on it until we see
the data to prove that we're right cuz
there's so many things that I couldn't
have predicted like you know okay I
didn't know how I didn't know that
Footwear would be hit harder than
apparel generally you know that seems
like a or or I didn't realize how much
luxury was gonna get hit you know I was
talking to another lender and they were
saying that their length you know their
borrowers are struggling because they
can't lower their prices and because
they lower their prices it takes away
the brand quality right and that you
know people kind of know that but you
you gets hit harder than you expect you
know beauty you know things like beauty
and staples are doing well I didn't
expect podcasts streaming to be as down
as it is compared to music streaming you
know and then you start thinking about
things like okay well 90% of Spotify his
revenue is subscriptions not ad spend
like there's all these things like you
just didn't think about before all this
occurred I think in a month and a half
two months from now you'll start to see
data as data starts to prove out your
theses and hypotheses yeah lean into it
but until then have the hypothesis and
know what the data you would need to see
is to go take action on it but trying to
convince yourself you're the smartest
person in the room right now especially
if it's your first time going through a
crisis I don't know doesn't doesn't seem
like it be prepared but don't go too
early well in another piece of this I
think is there's a big difference
between what I'll call it the
traditional Main Street small business
and
a technology enabled kind of
venture-backed business and if you
really think about the technology
enabled venture-backed business they
almost have this expectation early on
the reason why they raise money is
because they're gonna operate at a loss
for some period of time things like how
much runway do I have what's my burn
like that's kind of built into the model
and the belief is over time you'll
become profitable and grow and and you
know get more customers etc the small
businesses don't operate like that right
most small businesses are kind of very
thin margins they're profitable or
breakeven in that sense and they don't
have big cash you know in a bank account
and so it almost feels like venture
backed businesses just in the mindset of
how they grow that they operate at
losses for a while etc and then have
raised money to have these runways or in
a little bit better position in the
small businesses that might only have
two to three weeks of cash and if
revenue goes to zero they just can't
they just can't do it
right yeah I think that's always been
the case you know I think we're noticing
that you know might change how people
choose what companies to join right you
know it people might realize oh my gosh
a small business doesn't really have a
lot of cash and do I really want that to
be my employer I but I think the
reactions probably gonna be the
government's gonna say well we sort of
rely on small businesses to exist that
was really bad we probably don't want
that to happen again and so let's come
up with some sort of like program where
we're able to move faster you know that
yes the whole idea that the SBA was
gonna move fast and like be old it
should be cash quickly did feel like if
you believed it you should probably
change your career you know like the SBA
is like the DMV of Finance and we're
sort of seeing that happen now and on
top of that you know if you're a bank
you're you just lose lose lose either
you originate small business loans
quickly but it's really hard to do your
kyc AML so you get fined you do it
slowly and you get yelled at for doing
it slowly you decide not to because what
and you get yelled at for not doing it
we're not having an SBA license or you
do it quickly and you charge enough in
origination and servicing fees where you
can kind of withstand future fines so
that you can lend quickly and
get mad at you for having made a lot of
money on it there's just no win here
right and so like you got to actually
create aligned incentives for the
originators of these loans to actually
get them to go do it but right now if
you're a bank you have so much PTSD from
the reputation you create yourself in a
way that you're like is it really worth
it do I need to be doing this and then
if you're a bank you're definitely not
gonna make a new loan to somebody who
isn't already your client because you
know the KYC and AML of that is so hard
like why would you take the risk
and there's so much fraud that occurs
during a crisis um that is just not
worth potentially getting taken
advantage of I also think it'll change
how SN B's Bank like I think is my Bank
SD a license is gonna matter soon yeah
is the fraud thing lately explain that a
little bit more when you talk about
there's a lot of fraud and kind of just
nefarious activity in crisis if you were
a terrorist organization and you knew
that banks were gonna be making loans at
a faster rate than normal and you're
trying to figure out how to get cash
this might be a good time to try to get
cash from a bank yeah it's like that's
the thinking of it right and enduring
any fraud one people get desperate right
so they need money and fraught you fraud
occurs there's two types of fraud
there's fraud where it's a good person
who got desperate and does a bad thing
and there's fraud where it's a bad
person who intentionally did a bad thing
even though they didn't need to do a bad
thing
the first type starts to happen more in
times like this
look if you got lay it off and you don't
have another job and you're kind of like
worried because your kids are at home I
don't know when you when you care more
about like fraud or your kids safety
your kids food so yeah there's gonna be
more phishing attacks there's gonna be
more hackers so it's gonna be more fake
news there's gonna be more people you
know trying to commit fraud in the
system if you knew that there was gonna
be 350 billion dollars of SBA loans
being doled out right now and you were a
bad actor it seems like a pot of money
that you might try to go after yeah it's
probably gonna end up being more than
this I saw that they're already talking
about another 250 billion possibly to
try to backstop some the small business
stuff yeah let's get to 350 billion out
first you know like
the what's crazy to me I think is how
bad the information is like I feel even
the first day there was like conflicting
reports of how many people had applied
how much you know those loan
applications were worth etc and then the
government really wants us to know you
know like I think that they're kind of
like you know there's they're good
data's best hope is second best and bad
data is worse we're in hope yeah it's a
good way to look at it to the trends
that I know that you spent a lot of time
are on maybe because you guys have a
portfolio companies is one ecommerce and
then to kind of add spend or the
advertising industry let's start with
e-commerce what are you guys seeing
there on the e-commerce side that you
think is either interesting or people
should should be paying attention to I
mean look I think this is a it's been a
great time for e-commerce generally to
show the world that it really meant like
the variable cost of an e-commerce
business are really important you know
if you think about how an e-commerce
business is built you know it's cogs its
your sort of software services your
website stuff like that and it's
marketing spend and you have employees
if you're a big e-commerce company you
might have a warehouse and inventory by
the way you have your inventory lender
you know God knows they don't want your
inventory because if you can't sell it
they can't sell it and then you might
have more employees at normal but by the
way if you haven't warehouse you
probably have more cash than the average
small business maybe but you can toggle
that up and down if you have a physical
retail location you have your rent you
have a lot of fixed costs that you can't
toggle up and down and on top of that
people can still shop online so
ecommerce our hypothesis right now is
it's gonna be hit a lot less badly than
most it's really hard to predict where
consumer demands gonna go down as more
and more people are laid off it's gonna
be bad
however like you know I know I I
probably spent a third of what I
normally spend last month because I'm
just not going out and not doing stuff
so I have you know the average
individual is probably generating more
excess cash if they are employed they
may go online and shop that's what I
mean by you know in one hand you could
be an e-commerce company say oh my god
now's a great time to play off and speak
I know where the world's going all my
competitions going down but there's so
many competing variables that like okay
so people are spending less maybe they
have more time to shop online people are
getting laid off maybe demands gonna go
down you know it's just too hard like
it's too hard to know so you know I
can't give too much confidential
information on e-commerce other than
those sort of general data points on
advertising you know we're seeing a
handful of sort of factors one is views
are way up people are at home they're on
screens and are watching more and CPMs
are way down part of the reason CPMs are
down is because if you were spending a
million dollars a month and that was
your budget and now the use have doubled
your CPI owns will just come down in
half but you know you're seeing slight
decreases in ad spend right now in the
last two weeks of March you're seeing
way more views than normal and different
parts of the ad market I get got to get
hit differently you know print radio TV
things that are hard to measure and are
expensive are gonna get really hit
social video just you know banner ads
less hit because they're easier to
measure and the CPMs are cheaper and so
you can get a better bang for your buck
you know and then by the way if you
really are something like if you're
peloton or your Hulu or you're something
like that you're gonna get a better ROI
on your ad spend now than ever and so
you might start leaning in because
there's less noise
so we're basically seeing ads CPM is
coming way down views going way up and
ad spend generally being down five to 20
percent depending on the medium and I
can imagine as been going down 20 to 50
percent but that some platforms are
gonna perform way better than others and
I would be pretty bearish on media
companies that sell premium high CPMs
and more bullish on media companies that
have exchanges and so generally lower
CPMs snap sells at a lower CPM than
Instagram
that's a bullish comment YouTube sells a
lower CPM than Instagram
that's a bluish comment yeah thing
the other thing is um you know Spotify
people aren't turning off their Spotify
subscriptions and the last thing that
sort of is an interesting observation is
companies are turn people have
traditionally looked at LTVs and an
enterprise sales revenue as stickier
than consumer generated revenue like a
Netflix subscription feels less sticky
than enterprise software for enterprise
software that you see a bigger dip then
you see in consumer apps because people
are still at home watching Netflix and
they don't have a CFO of their personal
life negotiating with all their
different vendors and Netflix doesn't
care about any one subscriber but if
you're 2% of the revenue of a company or
if you're even 20 basis points of
revenue of a company that's huge and so
I bet you end up seeing more negotiation
and decrease the prices of enterprise
often you see a consumer yeah that makes
sense when you put it that way does this
change you think people's view of kind
of ad-supported businesses versus
subscription businesses like what
exactly what you're talking about almost
changing the way that people think about
how they build their business in the
future I think that uh you know
enterprise software will probably be
thought of as cyclical going forward I
think one of the things that people you
know we talk a lot about internally is
what does the consumer cap stack look
like and historically you know you've
always said ok well you know your home
loan and your auto loan or probably the
most senior and then it's like you know
utility bills and then it's like credit
card and then it's like unsecured stuff
and then it's like you're Nordstrom's
card and you look at default rates per
consumer and you kind of like go up and
down that stack just like a corporate
you know cap stacking says you have your
senior letter your secured lenders your
on secured lenders whatever and then
what we've always thought is Spotify
subscription like whatever your cheapest
per utility subscriptions are probably
more senior in your consumer cap stack
than most people think so I would
probably want to finance some spotify
subscription before I'd want to be their
credit card provider because I bet you
you don't pay your credit card bill but
you still maybe find a way to pay your
Spotify bill the flipside that argument
as you pay your Spotify bill is your
credit card I don't know maybe but man
does it feel good to be providing this a
$9 99
cent per month service that is probably
being used a ton if you're out of work
or your smartphone or Netflix compared
to like a credit card so it's just it'll
be interesting I think we're gonna have
a bunch of new data around what default
rates and what churn looks like after
this that we never had before yeah did
the thing I think I run the ad supported
businesses - is that advertiser who had
the million bucks and you know views
have gone up two times so now all of a
sudden they're paying 50% less CPMs at
some point if we stay in this quarantine
I wonder if there's an impact on sales
that changes their CAC and LTV
calculations right so literally just
because you have the million dollars to
advertise if no one's buying your
product at some point do you literally
just say hey we're not gonna advertise
right so well it almost like dries up
because sales dry up yeah
I mean I think people are definitely
start running bearable in base case LTVs
you know one of the things that people
always say like LTV has become this sort
of like initially kakda LTV was
everyone's like holy grail metrics and I
think in the last couple years people
become a lot less enchanted by LTVs
because what you do is you take your
monthly revenue and you take six months
of total churn data and assume that's
what's gonna last forever and you come
up with some number that looks very
close to infinity in terms like what
your LTV is and I think people are gonna
start to say like what is your LTV in
different environments so I do you think
that it's actually going to become a
more useful metric again because people
are going to know how to measure it
instead of just looking at it's like oh
don't worry my turn in my first four
months is zero so it means that my LTV
is like 93 quadrillion you know so I
also think that we're going I think the
last crisis saw a shift towards digital
ads and I think that you're gonna see
another shift there away from print TV
and traditional sources and I don't
think people gonna be really doing a lot
of billboard ads right now that doesn't
seem like a very good idea you know so I
think you're gonna see somewhat
permanent chefs but I also think that
you're gonna see you know companies like
the New York Times and others who have
relied on premium CPMs they've already
started going more and more towards
subscription revenue again in paid
revenue and I think as things like kovat
show it's how much bad information there
is out there if you're going to keep
paid up and I know that I've picked up
probably two
for subscriptions well I've been home
I'm just reading more and watching more
I don't think I'm gonna turn off of them
I think that's gonna be the deal that's
plug in via forever shift yeah you know
what you're also like on the
subscription side there's some things
you know we don't watch a Netflix show
every single night right but it's
something that is cheap enough where I
couldn't even actually tell you how much
it is is it 9 bucks 10 bucks 12 bucks
whatever I use when you say not watching
every night you're not looking me into
that right because I am but it's like
let's say that you've got I don't know
most people probably have somewhere
between 4 to 10 subscriptions right that
they're paying for across various
services and some of those like a
Spotify you probably actually do use
every day right if you go to the gym you
listen podcast whatever but that other
things you may use once or twice a week
and some of you actually may only use
once or twice a month and what I think
starts to happen is the businesses
themselves will actually change the way
that they think about the proper service
right the more that you can kind of
become a daily habit I think also
changes and so it almost then brings you
to something like a kwibi versus a
Netflix right where these the kwibi
thing is basically 10 minutes short-form
content you're suppose to be able to
consume it you know much quicker
yeah cetera versus let's sit down and
watch an hour and a half documentary I
don't know if it'll prove out but but I
think that that has to enter the
conversation at some point for people
who are looking at the
subscription-based businesses as well
the kwibi thing will be interesting I
mean I think a lot of like I'm not I
don't know jack about storytelling
except did I always remember and I
actually I'm gonna board with kind of
put the construct for built the contract
for me he's like you know if you look at
John Christian book John Grisham does
this awesome thing where he creates like
you know very short chapters and he
always has three subplots running and so
at the end of every chapter you have a
subplot that gets extinguished and
you're really interested to know what's
gonna write on a clip like on a
cliffhanger and you get to the next
chapter you're sort of wondering so you
read that chapter to keep getting to the
next chapter we're gonna find out and
then there's another cliffhanger then
you read the third chapter another
cliffhanger you finally get the answer
to the first cliffhanger and then you
creates another right and so if kwibi
you can kind of create that dynamic with
their audio
where there's always a cliffhanger where
you come back the next day I think
that'd be interesting
I don't know that'll be true or not who
knows but I do agree that this daily
habit thing is important and I do agree
that cost per utility of use is going to
be a really really important metric you
know what's the value like I wonder if
there's gonna be a KPI that starts
coming out which is how much do people
spend for every minute they're on
Netflix and I bet you if you looked at
like the $9.99 you pay for Netflix and
you look at and then you divide that by
how many minutes per month that'd be
super fascinating to know that metric
compared to Hulu compared to Disney plus
the other thing by the way that kwibi
reminds me of is it's a short-duration
asset so in lending like let's imagine
you lend you make five year loans you
know in one case that's not so good
because you have to take a five year
view on the economy a five year view on
the company and so people say well if
you make a 30 day loan it's really easy
to predict what's gonna happen in 30
days the problem is so every once in a
while it's not right like I don't know
maybe there's gonna be some virus that
starts in a country and spreads to all
the other countries and everyone stays
home for a while right and you know that
was gonna happen
all of a sudden your book of 30 day
assets all gets correlated to one and
goes to zero because we all stop paying
payable at this month and then on the
five year loan you know you basically
look at your default rate and you say
well my annualized default rate for two
to three months it's super bad but then
over the duration of the whole asset
base you know I had out of five years
six really bad months so the thing
performed okay in general but the short
duration of the asset you know the more
your whole thing can get wiped out and
if you look at the effect of the fault
rates often people say oh well factoring
for example is like 15 45 90 day
receivables and you'll see the fault
rates in like the two to four percent
range sometimes you have to analyze that
out so if you see two percent defaults
every month it's really the twenty four
percent default rate kwibi I think will
in some ways be entered in a similar
thing where I am curious how many false
positives you're gonna get where people
download kwibi but they can't get hooked
on these short stories and they just
fall off but
now I'm not I'm a storyteller I don't
have good taste I've never liked
something before everyone else like and
then like all of a sudden became popular
so I'm not there I got to ask what what
um have you noticed any changes in the
things that you're consuming on your
phone so obviously we're all spending
more time in front of computers TVs
phones etc just by nature of sitting
home but have you started to consume
content from other platforms that maybe
weren't before or you notice hey you
know I'm spending a lot more time on
Instagram where he previously was
Twitter or something like that I'm
finally I am finally reading my
newsletters that I get because I've had
a bit more time to do that but I'm find
myself spending a lot less time reading
The Wall Street Journal and hearing what
somebody's interpretation of what an
expert said and instead just looking for
data like I don't I don't need and it by
the way I think reporters are doing a
good job this is not like it dig on
anything like but I'm less interested in
seeing like a two-page article analyzing
something that an industry expert
observed from talking to someone else
instead I'm like alright just tell me
the export I want to see the CSV yeah
super interesting before we finish up
two minutes on a bit coin and crypto
you've you've previously described
herself as crypto curious what uh what
are you thinking there I'm or any kind
of thoughts I was super bummed to see
Bitcoin get crushed when the market
started to go into sort of panic mode
because it was supposed to be a safe
haven and you know everything's
correlate yeah everything's correlated
was truly true that week it started to
rebound I don't have any observation to
other than let's see where we land two
months from now and how it ends up
behaving dogs and other markets but I'm
really in wait-and-see move mode but I
think it's hard for something to be a
store value when it dropped that far
that fast I mean there was a night and I
think maybe we both remember that night
where like I was on my phone texting
everyone all my loved ones being like I
don't know maybe it's all done you know
like
that's scary position on being the the
Black Thursday I told you this and I'll
say it on here I never thought the day
would come where Polina had to look at
me and be like it's gonna be okay but
seeing it drop 50% a single day it was
just like it almost took your breath
away to actually watch it happen yeah I
mean look I think the whole like Bitcoin
thing is like I don't trust the
government the government's shitty like
the government's trying to take all your
information like the government if you
act out I just throw you in jail and
there's like a lot of negatives about
having a government you know but you
know they do it like there's like an
army you know that's pretty good and you
know people are giving [ __ ] to the
Postal Service like yeah it probably
should be those like government entity
that like make sure letters you know if
FedEx goes bankrupt we'll still get to
where it needs to go even if it takes
freaking ever you know like so I do
think this utility to a government and I
don't know like I didn't go into this
thing knowing anything really about
Steven nation I probably think more
positively of him though now then my
sort of neutral view I had on him a few
months ago and I think he has the
benefit of seeing Hank Paulson drag drag
drag Congress Senate and you know
pundits the mud to save our economy last
time at least you had the playbook and
then government showed that like it's
really important and it's important
because they can do great things like
stimulate the economy and they can do
shitty things like have some president
who doesn't can't speak in full
sentences confuse the nation right and
like I think if you're gonna sit there
and say that the government is doing
things wrong and be annoyed at the
government by definition you're saying
how important the government is and
Bitcoin doesn't have a government yeah
it is a it's one of these things where
time will ultimately tell us the answer
but it is absolutely fascinating to be
living through this right now and kind
of watching it all unfold because it
feels like every day there's something
new whether good or bad but it's just
really really interesting to kind of
watch it all play out so I appreciate
you doing this we're we're good we're
good they want the one thing I'm doing
is I'm trying
sort of take notes everyday you know I
encourage anyone else to do the same
thing which is you know eight years from
now you're gonna look back and see what
you're dealing notes were because it's
gonna be really easy to look at March
and April at the same day and you know
for example Friday could not understand
the market Monday what the hell happened
to the equity markets how are they up so
much and so I wrote in my little notepad
like oh man markets gonna get crushed
tomorrow they were flat they were flat
you know and like I'm really glad I have
that note that eight years from now I
can actually look at my daily playbook
and like every day I read a hypothesis
will happen tomorrow and what'll happen
60 days from now I talk about my
observations and it just shows you you
know a lot of these predictions I had a
lot of conviction on and they were wrong
so can we start a daily tweet from ollie
on what the market will do tomorrow and
then now it will measure the accuracy no
way cuz my compliance team would never
let me and I would never do that to
people because that's a way following
that is a way to lose money alright
where can the we're gonna go find you on
Twitter and find co-venture yeah I mean
I'm at al ly be Hamed on Twitter you
know I I respond to most DMS unless it's
like weird don't send me weird stuff and
then I'm knowing how knowing some of the
people follow you on twitter and then
I'm yeah I'm not gonna give my email
address out I'm around
alright Wisco Vizier's website
co-venture bc
sounds good man I appreciate doing this
we will have do it again stay safe I'll
look forward to seeing lunch money later
today
yeah I appreciate it I feel like this
check you're the second best person on
that show oh yeah of course I mean
listen I I don't even like admitting it
but polina literally scolds me for not
for not participating or performing up
to her standards so it is what it is
she's really good I think it's more
about her being good than you being bad
I think you're both good she's just good
her I appreciate that your your lifting
my spirits in a time of dire stress
you Anthony you can't help it she's so
good but how are you supposed to ever
live up to that it's not Ali is being
very kind
while his fiance sits in the same room
as him and my fiance sits in the room
with me so we're both the the two
intelligent folks complements all right
all right talk soon my friend Thank You
taki Cindy
all right perfect I will I'm gonna
afford this to you right after it gets
done processing in zoom and then just
send it to whoever much give me a thumbs
up will will post it tomorrow morning
I probably thanks you later